مرحبا يعطيكم العافيه اليوم راح نحكي عن
موضوع ثبات الوزن بعد الحميه الغذائيه
يعني انا بعمل حميه غذائيه بس لازم فيها
وبلعب رياضه بس وزني بضل ثابت بعد اسبوعين
ثلاثه من الحمير غذائيه شو الحل مشاكل راح
نحكيها بالتفاصيل بشكل عام وبعتمد على
السكر الموجود في الدم كمصدر الرئيسي بعد
هيك جسمنا مخزون السكر اللي هو البلاد على
شان الكسره يستمد منه ومع تكسر السكر
بتكون جسمك فقط هي كميه كثير كبيره من
المايك عشان هيك الناس بتعملها
بعد اسبوع اللي عند اخصائي التغذيه شوفوا
وزنها كم صار بتكون من ثلاث اربع كيلو
النزول عندهم وهذا اغلبهم بيكون ماء مش
دهون اخذ سياره ممكن ان الجسم يلج علشان
يحصل على الطاقه هي تكسير الدهون طبعا هو
اصعب خيال الجسم اللي ياخذ طاقه لانه
الجسم
او يحافظ على كتله الدهنيه وما يخسرها فمن
هون بتبلش عنا مشاكل تبعثي له كيف نحل هاي
المشكله طبعا حلها بسيط لانه احنا بنلعب
في عدد السعرات الحراريه ما اخلي جسمي
يعتمد على عدد السعرات حراريه كل يوم نفس
الشيء يعني اذا اخذتوا اليوم 1500 سعره
حراريه بكره باخذ 1,600 الي بعد باخذ 1300
وهكذا ثاني بحال طبعا اللي هو الرياض لان
الرياضه بتزيد عندي القطعه العضليه ولما
تزيد الكتله العضليه يعني بيزيد نسبه حرق
الدهون عدي على البيوت طبعا لانه احمد
لازم ابتعد عن السكريات والنشاويات نزيك
استهلاك الالياف ونسيت شرب الماء وتشيك
على الغده الدرقيه والنشاطها ويشيك على
مقاومه الانسولين